نائبه الرئيس الامريكي ثم نعود اليك
الان
النقيب ما زالت صامده
رشا
وروسيا اصبحت اضعف
تحالف
النيت اصبح اقوى من اي وقت مضى
[تصفيق]
والاهم من هذا كله
ان معنويات الشعب الاوكراني
صامده وتحت
رئاسه بايدن رئيس الولايات المتحده ابدت
دولتنا قياده حاسمه وكما شارى بايدن فان
الولايات المتحده ستدعم اوكرانيا
لطالما استلزم الامر لن نتهاون واليوم في
[موسيقى]
هذا المؤتمر مؤتمر ميونخ الامني
اصفوا كل
ما يقف تحت المحق وهو المصلحه الاخلاقيه
والاستراتيجيه والسبب الذي يجعل اوكرانيا
مهمه لشعب امريكا
ولشعب اوروبا
ولشعوب العالم كامله
بدايه منذ الايام الاولى لهذه الحرب غير
المبرره شاهدنا
قوات روسيه
تدخل في اعمال بشعه
وجرائم حرب
وكانت تستهدف اعمالهم قيمنا المشتركه
وهجوم استهدفت انسانيتنا المشتركه دعونا
نكون واضحين فان القوات
الروسيه سعد
لهجمات
موسعه ومنتظمه ضد
سكان مدنيين
اعمال بشعه من قتل وتعذيب
واغتصاب وتهجير
وابعاد
وايضا
اعدامات وضرب
وتعذيب بالكهرباء
والقوات الروسيه
هجرت مئه الالاف من اوكرانيا الى روسيا
بمن فيهم الاطفال
فصل فصلوا
الاطفال عن اسرهم
وكلنا راينا صور
المسرح في ميرا بول مئات الذين قتلوا
دعونا نفكر
بسوره المراه الحامل التي قتلت
في اعقاب ضربه استهدفت
مستشفى ولاده كانت تعد من اجل عمليه الوضع
صور
للمدنيين الذين يقتلون بدم بارد وجثثهم
تترك على
قارعه الطريق
وسوره الرجل الذي كان يركب دراجته
فلنفكر
بالفتاه
الاربعه اعوام
التي تعرضت
لاستهداف من الجندي الروسي قام باغتصابها
اعمال غير انسانيه وبربريه
وقبل ان اكون نائبه رئيس الولايات المتحده
كنت قد قضيت معظم عملي كمدعي عام وكنت
محاما بدات في
قاعه المحاكم ومن ثم
ارتفعت لان اصل الى مداعم انا اعرف
اهميه جمع المعلومات
والوقوف
امام القانون وفي حاله
اعمال روسيا في اوكرانيا
شهدنا الادله كلنا نعلم
المعايير القانونيه
وما من شك ابدا
ان هذه جرائم ضد الانسانيه
[تصفيق]
الولايات المتحده
عزمت مسبقا على ان روسيا
اكدت انها قامت بجرائم ضد الانسانيه
واقول هنا
[موسيقى]
لكل من ارتكبوا هذه الجرائم
ولمسؤوليهم
المتورطين في هذه والمتامرين في هذه
الجرائم
ستحاسبون على افعالكم
وفي وجهي
هذه الحقائق غير المشكوك بها لنا نحن
جميعا هنا في ميونخ دعونا نجدد التزامنا
تجاه المحاسبه
دعونا
نجدد التزامنا
لسياده القانون
اما بالنسبه للولايات المتحده
اذا استمعنا واياكم مشاهدينا الكرام لكلمه
كمالها الرئيس الامريكي في مؤتمر ميونخ
قالت بين روسيا اصبحت اقوى
ومجرم الحرب في اوكرانيا لن يفلتوا من
العقاب وبان الولايات المتحده لن يتعاونون
في دعم اوكرانيا